there's more on the ballot in 2016 than
the giant train wreck on national
television let's stop rubbernecking for
a minute and take a look at six other
important things at stake on november
eighth pot is on the ballot and nine
states which means some form of
legalized marijuana could potentially
exist in 29 states that could be a
tipping point for reform as public
approval for marijuana is at an all-time
high Maine is tired of having a governor
that more people voted against than
voted for so they came up with question
5 which would implement ranked choice
voting in the state it's a system
designed to remove the third-party
spoiler effect with voters ranking their
candidates and dropping last place
finishers until someone has a majority
minimum wage hikes are on the ballot in
four states but one to watch a South
Dakota which seems to have realized the
negative effect a higher minimum wage
has on youth employment and would
decrease the minimum wage for workers
under the age of 18 while three states
grapple with putting convicted criminals
to death Colorado might legalize killing
yourself prop 106 would allow assisted
suicide for those who have been
diagnosed with the terminal illness and
have less than six months to live
pushing the government out of
end-of-life decisions California prob 61
would prohibit state agencies from
paying more for prescription drug than
what the Department of Veterans Affairs
pays no one knows for sure what the
outcome of that would be but it just
might be like that time in 1990 when
Congress tried to do exactly the same
thing with Medicaid back then drug
companies responded by raising prices on
drugs sold to the VA and soon enough
Congress repealed its mandate but in
defiance of history economics and
opposition campaigns outspending
supporters by around a hundred million
dollars polls indicate that the measure
will probably pass
the first vote one big question on
Election Day will be how many votes can
Gary Johnson poulan if he hits the five
percent threshold the Libertarian Party
would be classified as a minor party and
be eligible for matching public election
funds now will they take government
money with strings attached let's cross
that bridge when they get there for more
election 2016 coverage visit reason.com